and there's multiverses in in the film
there was a world where Jackie Chan was
going to make this film yes no no okay I
to be fair to the Daniels and you know
when you start out to write a movie or
to do a movie you want it is show
business right it's about a business
sense and constantly it's the guys
that goes out to save the world then as
you get older and the the roles get
smaller the boxes get tighter
so um they did they went to China to
meet with Jackie and you know Jackie
text me and said you know that
congratulations for your movie but did
you know your boys came to see me first
I'm like
no no it's okay we're great friends I'm
like you're lost bro thanks
Michelle yo
[Applause]